hey reject nation its Greg Alva here
today we have with us movie reviewer
Andrew Hayes one of our longtime
followers also has his own movie channel
called the Andrew Hayes YouTube channel
Hayes Network and this guy really knows
his movies we often do Google Hangouts
and it's fun talking with this guy
because we love talking film a lot and I
thought like you know we're supposed to
do a google hangout this month Andrew
when we do a video together at this time
is the first time we're ever doing this
we're just doing a video together and he
lives all the way in Jersey so we never
get a chance to collab in person I
thought let's take advantage of this
Google hangout time and let's do
something a little different let's talk
about our favorite YouTube channels the
YouTube channels we actually watch a lot
hang on our own time side it's gonna be
more of a free-form discussion type of
video hopefully one of your channels
gets mentioned in here I actually don't
know what Andrew watches I just assumed
we're the only channel he likes to watch
and I think that's true I think it's
true I'm pretty sure his whole list is
gonna be Greg and John but how are you
Andrew I hope you are because you look
happy
you look grizzly happy you look you
kinda you look like someone I wouldn't
trip you look like a wannabe rapper I
think the beard in the headphones in the
cap makes you look like I'm getting into
the rap game dropping that mixtapes
well yeah I'll kick it off I think a
channel that I probably go to the most
out of every channels that I watch
because they're not my number one
channel I definitely have an answer that
I'm saving for later for what my number
one channel is but the channel that I
tend to watch the most would have to be
screen junkies news screen junkies movie
news they always have a great panel of
people that they often alternate with
usually Roth cornets
one who's monitoring the panel usually
get Dan on there usually get Spencer
Gilbert you get Joe star on their lawn
Harris dannielle Radford you get a whole
bunch of you and they usually get guest
stars and oftentimes they get famous
people I just watch the episode not long
ago at Jason Blum on there and I think
they're they're so good because they
have this loose quality like they have
such a professional set like I love
honest trailers everyone knows that and
I and I watch movie fights often but in
terms of like what i watch daily I I
would have to say I watched those guys
daily I usually get a lot of my movie
news information from what they're
talking about
and yeah I love those guys you watch a
movie news channel do you watch a movie
news channel I don't like religiously
keep up with any particular movie news
channel except for what will inevitably
be my favorite channel in this video
which is a movie channel but you know
we're saving the favorites for last yeah
I want to just jump that shark I mean
yeah I don't we do so much movie related
stuff and we do we do so much movie news
already that usually when I go to
youtube it's for stuff that's other than
that at least for the bulk of my like
down time viewing because when I'm
watching he usually happens that when
I'm watching collide or when I'm letting
screen junkies I'm a little more engaged
I'm a little bit more like I want to
absorb I want to you know this is my
arena so I need to be you know paying
attention to this and looking at it more
academically maybe it is fun but but
yeah in terms of like movie news I don't
I don't religiously what about you
Andrew what movie channels do you watch
like the main oh you watch like Collider
movie talk yeah why they get hotter
girls on there or something
I I think I don't watch movie talk as as
much as I'd like to I can listen to
movie talk a lot like they're more of a
podcast to me like they're the kind of
guys where if if they're you know they
usually have a pretty good panel they I
don't know like there's something like
the more I like the more loose vibe like
I like double toasted a lot too and they
they have like that loose vibe where it
is I feel like on movie talk Collider
like there'll be times I break in a joke
so many times where they're just messing
around but I also feel like they're more
of like this serious guys talking movie
news you know like they're there to
really dish it out and they're on a
clock you know like I can feel the
ticking time clock we're live right now
I know a street dog is the same thing
but I'm more aware of when colliders
doing it and I also think because we go
on the Schmo down and I often see these
guys if I watch them too often all I
might start to put them on a pedestal a
little too high was Ric Christian and
Marc I'm already like when I see schmoes
on the same way an ashram I was like
when I went to Jeremy John's is the same
way like so what by the time it comes to
like actually being around them I'm like
I don't want to be in that position
where I feel like a lot more less and
little because I hadn't so aware of them
and I watch them all the time that
there's become this separation I don't
know how to put it I like movie trivia
and I like the fun you know sort of
discussing movies and stuff it gets a
little intense for me when we're really
breaking down movie news because there's
so much of it and for me as a viewer to
like we watch a lot of movies we talk
about movies we breakdown trailers we
review films and after a while knowing
so much and dissecting the news side of
it to me I kind of start to draw a
distance for myself from that because I
don't want too much of that rattling
around my brain when I'm just trying to
take in a film you know yeah and I feel
like nowadays the veil between behind
the scenes and
scenes is uh non-existent I kind of
create the barrier for myself and I
figure any any movie news I'm gonna need
to hear about is gonna find me it's not
gonna pass me by well what other
channels you watch Andrew one that I
really like because I've been watching
him pretty much since the beginning he's
done like you know like games like
half-life 2 found all the way to he did
a full hundred percent let's play do you
play video games are you posing right
now are you trying to act like you play
games we know well let's see how much a
real gamer you are have you ever played
I don't know something recently crash
bandicoot you ain't a real gamer then
Andrew Hayes you a not a real gamer what
about Mario and 64 of course alright you
my homie
you my homie what about pong I love pong
you know what game I'm addicted to this
spider-man unlimited app there's a game
spider-man unlimited app it's the most
amazing app you'll ever play buddy
I'm telling you that well so okay so you
watch gaming and movie channel what
other gamers you watch I don't watch any
gaming channels
one that I really like he's my favorite
so I don't want to spoil that one for
saving that one till the end pewdiepie
it's in the gamer and he's your favorite
YouTube channel yes
markiplier it is not us yes you are
making this Google hangout so
uncomfortable right now I want you to
know it is you oh I got asked this you
watch Tyrone Magnus hell yeah
you watch us but not Tyrone it's nice
it's nice to have someone watch up I
mean he has like what other reaction
channels do you watch and that's really
I was really broken it down for me you
know what you know what reaction there's
a reactor out there who I just freaking
love and he knows I love them I've sent
him a message to like this if there's a
reaction channel I would really
recommend to you guys it's us do from
New Zealand Asian guy with a New Zealand
accent named che have you ever seen him
Andrew he's so funny he's like a funny
ass dude and I think we're kind of
similar in our personalities it's
probably why I love them so much because
like our style and how we like
to approach our reaction videos is the
same and he is one funny ass dude man
and I really wanted to meet up with the
guy he's all the way in New Zealand so
I'm never gonna see him but yeah they're
great they're great late to the party
another great reaction channel I really
like I like the reaction channels where
they really can talk about movies like
the movie couple with Wendy Lee is on
there there's a girl named there's two
girls I could think of one is Tinker Jo
I think that's how you say her name and
have you heard of her
no Tinker Jasso and also this is girl I
think her name is Hillary but her
channel is called cinema siblings oh
yeah she does a great job they're good
finely tailored is great yeah so you
watch anyone from Collider gotcha gotcha
there's another gal who does I know at
least movie reviews and I think
reactions to and now I'm blanking on her
channel name it's like it's another one
where it's the channel has just an
actual it's called comics something
gotcha yeah do you watch all like the
movie reviewers too like the big ones my
god what about do you like the flick pic
yeah there's a category of three to me I
mean the schmoes are included here too
and I'm actually a black nerd comedy in
there as well yeah I like I love his
energy a lot he's really his own thing
and that's what I really love about him
and he's great we've collab with him and
two collabs him twice and yeah he's
great at what he does but I always I
always associate John's and stuckman
and flick pick flicking flicking jerk
yeah John I always associated them in
the end is in the end the three because
I feel I watch them all the time and I
think Jeremy John's
the best like quick snappy reviews the
short ones and stuckman has like the
analytical really broken down movie
reviews and I feel like flick pick is
he's buff what I love about flick pick
is he's kind of like a hybrid of them I
think he's got that snappy energy
because he's he's always on steroids and
caffeine he's ready to get a pump in at
any moment but he's also got that's like
really great analytical side to because
he's got this humor and this energy so I
feel like he's got like John Jeremy
John's anchor Stockman combined into one
massive buff machine who he is yeah
[Music]
that's a great way to put it
that's a great way to put I'm sure I
think of like you know this there's some
great another channel there's a channel
I feel like I learned a lot from because
I know on um on YouTube we often do
reactions to what culture which does
these like great list videos and I think
and I know you you really like WatchMojo
a lot don't you what are the list video
channels you mainly watch well who do
like list and wrestling oh you got a
wide range of like what you really watch
on YouTube I'm like I have a very nish
oh my god like here's what I go to to
watch what's it called it's like if
sometimes what culture would cover some
wrestling right have you ever seen the
channel and Cinna fix yes Cinna fix is
probably my favorite list channel the
thing is I need my brain on when I'm
watching those guys because like I can
watch walk culture or WatchMojo or even
Screen Rant for that
matter and and I'll be able to I could
just watch them like no problem but
Cinna fix feels like oh I'm in I'm in
film school right now
I need to have my brain on and make sure
I'm absorbing everything they're saying
because they they they throw a lot of
great film technicality definitions and
words at you all day long and they
really know how to break stuff down and
their categories are so unique the way
they the way they list their videos is
so unique that I feel like I'm in film
school when I listen those guys so I
wish I could listen to them a little
more often because like other list
channel videos I could listen to them
but works in a fix I have to sit down
and watch I need them visuals so I can
really absorb what they're talking about
so that they're they're more specific
niche for me there so you watch
wrestling gaming and I don't know the
category out there is it there can't you
watch like other channels that are not
me what every time I hear you've
listening is something it's always
something not movie related yeah I mean
typically when I'm just chilling I I
watch a lot of music related stuff so
like my favorite music channel is the
needle drop Anthony Fantana I really
like his reviews you know I don't even
always agree with him but I just always
like where he's coming from and I like
his taste in things and you know
sometimes to piggyback off that when I
want to listen to more music related
stuff cuz that's really like my that's
where my mind goes when it's on my free
time like I just naturally look up like
interviews with people whose music I
like or reviews of records or
discussions or whatever so he's got a
couple channels he's got the needle drop
he's also got Fantana which is just a
little bit more loose it's a little bit
more like news or a random track here or
there and then I'll check out like a RTV
or Sean see sometimes to get my music
fix in those are sort of places I go a
lot for music rush I've started watching
more movie stuff in the philosophy realm
so like I really like wisecrack a lot
guys when they'll break down like shows
or movies in terms of
ah Sophie those are that's the movie
stuff I get into on yeah is that more
sort of academic stuff and then there's
also stuff like school of life I really
enjoy which they do a wide array of
things from like short little videos
with with appealing animations related
to either philosophy or life or
self-improvement
or you know history politics you know
it's a kind of a thoughtful Avenue that
I like to go down sometimes on YouTube I
gotta ask you this Andrew you watch
cinemasins yeah cinemasins is the
channel where I I just I can't watch
them because once I do I don't stop and
I'm just looking at my phone for two
hours watching them tear apart a bunch
like for quite some time
ya know I'm like that too no honest
trailers I mean I I've like gone back
and why like I think it's kind of
pointlessly what's the ones that we
obviously do reactions to his II watch a
lot of how much should have ended honest
trailers we watch a lot of there's a
movie channel that we got turned on to
at least I got turned on to thanks to
somebody on patreon which is nerdwriter
we watched that video about how David
Fincher guides your eye or whatever and
I started checking out more of their
videos and I yeah I really like that
kind of thing that sort of breakdown an
analysis the stuff that can help you
with your filmmaking there's a challenge
it's got a recently called film courage
where they interview like prolific
producers and screenwriters like people
who really work in this business and
they really give you the nitty gritty on
how to be a better whatever your
whatever profession you're pursuing and
yeah it just shows me how little I know
about film when I watch those things man
you know do you watch any vlog channels
[Music]
i I watch my girlfriend is super into
like this is her queen her idol oh
logger fitness model named Nikki black
header and I've seen a couple of her
videos she's really hot she's got a nice
personality
[Laughter]
I've never gotten into like people have
told us to do vlogs like once every six
months I just kissed him on the lips so
I found this guy he just oh you got like
old school which is one of my favorite
games of all time and right now he's
doing
just I love his energy and like like the
other guy loved his commitment and he's
another guy that just tries to do a
hundred percent show you all the little
secrets of what I love do you play games
and then do the Lutz place or do you
watch the Let's Plays and then play the
game see what I do is I watch the watch
i watch the the whatever the Supercuts
the what are those calls the cutscenes
the cutscenes i watch the the cutscenes
and then i tell people i played the game
and that way i can fit in and all the
geek parties I go to or I'm like yeah I
know tomb raider I know she got the [ __ ]
kicked out of her in that game right
yeah yeah this movie looks kind of
accurate to the game majority I do
things like that my favorite YouTube
channel easily I there the definition of
guys who just don't give a [ __ ] about
what people think
cuz when you're but I think when you're
in the opinion based game of like movie
reviews and stuff you're open yourself
up to so much criticism because there's
something something that people want to
bag you on as your opinion and these
guys will like bag a movie that everyone
loves because they just don't care about
my favorite Channel easily is red letter
media they are so freaking hysterical
man yeah I love everything they do I
mean I'm not I'm actually not the
biggest fan of their sketches like they
had that reoccurring mr. plinkus sketch
that they would do the VCRs and him
getting married and all that but I love
their nerd crew I think their nerd crew
so freaking funny I love they do it
before before they see anything because
it's just like predictions
I was gonna go down but they act like
they've seen it it's so funny
they're half in the bag segment is like
the best reviews I could easily listen
to those guys all day but I even love
like their mr. blanket reviews where
they really break down a movie for like
an hour hour and a half it's so funny it
was so insightful at the same time
they're just the masters that not given
truly not giving a [ __ ] what people
think about them yeah like they don't
have like that attitude like I don't
care they just really don't care and
they bring a necessary element of biting
satire to our little arena they're so
indifferent yeah yeah and I find I find
something amusing about that tone of
voice in general even the weird little
reaction channels have started to pop up
like reaction tea time and stuff like
that I just get such a kick out of when
people kind of rib yeah what we do yeah
it's all fair you know what's your
favorite channel my favorite channel I
mean before before I go to my favorite
favorite channel officers want to shout
out first week feast because I devour
those hot hot ones episodes like it's
nobody's business and I where they get
celebrities then they eat why I have
started eating so much more hot sauce
since I watch that show just in hopes
that one day maybe I could compete yeah
and they've gotten they've gotten some
terrific guests especially lately they
just had like Michael B Jordan on so
like they're blowing up but my favorite
favorite favorite channel is double
toasted I've followed them since high
school when they were still spill comm
doing the animated movie reviews like
taking their podcast chopping them down
to five minutes
putting the reviews up on YouTube yeah
just my friend Paul in high school
turned me on to them and I've been
keeping up ever since so like yeah all
the things we've gotten to do and like
the closer we've come to them just the
more I eat because yeah there they are
for me what like screen junkies news is
for you like they are the movie and bam
pop culture channel that I can put on
and just listen to and hang out with and
kind of look forward to a new episode
every day
and like their balance of like fun and
humor and off-the-cuff nough swift that
movie news is kind of the the perfect
flavor for me so double toast toasted
alright add your any other channels you
want to watch or a channels you
recommend that we watch I do I think I
think I'm the only channel I actually
watch I'm pretty sure I mean I just I
just upload a video then I set my toilet
I open up my youtube creator studio app
and then I just watch myself that's cool
looking me and then I read comment and I
go wow they love me they hate me
[Laughter]
my mom comments telling me to get a real
job every time that's what she does she
says do something just comments reaction
yeah my mom comments and says that I'll
never be as successful as my brother
that's all she does well all right guys
what are your favorite YouTube channels
do you like to watch other than this one
if we are comment below let us know what
your favorite channels are I mean we got
we got insight into what we watch on our
downtime like what we actually that
we're not always doing reactions to or
something just we like to watch on her
downtime so put it down below you guys
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification I'll get notified
every time one of our videos is up make
sure to check out Andrew Hayes on the
Andrew Hayes YouTube channel link in the
description box link posted right here
on this video and check us out on
patreon weekly Q&A is you like our Q&A
segments Andrew I love good I'm gonna
we're gonna be coming back to you a
little bit do you like our full-length
TV show reactions Andrew Hopp / hey
somebody watches my Riverdale and what
about our music video that talks
really naturally it's really natural
what about the deleted takes me
occasionally post once we release the
blu-ray they're just gonna all be on
there thanks buddy all right guys we'll
catch you on the flippety-flip thanks
for being here Andrew